[Applaudissements]
qui témoigne de la conclusion d'une
entente sans précédent entre le
gouvernement fédéral et le constructeur
allemand Volkswagen l'usine de batterie
pour véhiculer électrique de Volkswagen
est un investissement qui va bénéficier
à plusieurs générations ici à Saint-Omer
c'est dans le sud de l'Ontario que verra
le jour la première usine de batterie du
fabricant allemand à l'extérieur de
l'Europe ces installations auront la
taille de 210 ce terrain soccer la
construction doit commencer l'an
prochain et se terminer en 2027
le Premier ministre ontarien se réjouit
déjà des retombées d’entente
l'usine ne produira annuellement des
batteries pour un million de voitures
électriques l'aide d'Ottawa pourrait
atteindre 13 milliards de dollars en
subventions c'est des montants qui sont
très importants mais c'est des montants
qui peuvent servir d'effet de levier
pour en permettant une usine de batterie
on permet aussi tout un écosystème
d'activité de logiciel de haute
technologie à lui seul ce projet va
permettre de créer jusqu'à 3000 emplois
directs et jusqu'à 30 000 emplois
indirects malgré ses retombées certains
observateurs estiment que 13 milliards
de dollars c'est beaucoup trop généreux
de la part de
taawaid
n’empêche d'autres estiment que le
gouvernement Trudeau n'avait pas d'autre
choix que de délier les cordons de la
bourse sans quoi le constructeur
automobile aurait pu choisir de
s'installer aux États-Unis cet
investissement secteur automobile un
secteur automobile en pleine
effervescence confronté à une transition
de plus en plus urgente au moment où les
indicateurs des changements climatiques
battent des records ici adiacin
Radio-Canada Montréal